Hey youtubers, it's Charlie! This is going
to be my Arrow Episode 7 video, so many awesome
fights in this episode. Probably because the
director was their fight coordinator. This
is also the last episode for the big Vandal
Savage crossover episode is happening in two
weeks talk about that at the end of the video
just careful for spoilers from episode seven
if you haven't seen it yet and the the reverse
flash ring giveaway is new again this week
oriented inner that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video starting with
number five Diggle uses the arrowmobile for
another creative takedown of one of the ghosts
this is so much fun to opening action sequence
great just the beginning of an entire episode
full of awesome fight sequences being choreographed
fight sequences the director of the episode
James Bamford is their fight coordinator is
one of the Best Buy coordinators in Vancouver
so of course any time they do stuff like this
it looks awesome but the best takedown was
Diggle using the arrow Mobile to like crash
into frame and take out one of those goes
if you member that's the exact same way Felicity
took down ravage her at the end of season
two but the whole point of that scene was
just to let you know that hive is trying to
destabilize the government in the area the
federal government was sending in money to
strengthen the banks the ghost just blew it
up they don't want the city to get any financial
assistance from the federal government and
that that also kind of ties in with this running
plot line across the first half of the season
Damien Darhk preparing the city for his associates
from hive to get here which I'd I think is
Vandal Savage's who is talking about on the
number for Damien Darhk meets all of her queen
at the campaign fundraiser so couldn't stop
thinking about whether or not Damien Darhk
actually knows all over is the green arrow
and I think as of their first conversation
in the episode he did not but I think by the
end of the episode he was putting the pieces
together is a smart man but you can see the
wheels turning in his head it's kind like
the flash season two watching Patty slowly
put the pieces together she's probably going
to figure out the berries the flash eventually
Damien Darhk gonna put the pieces together
that all of her is the green arrow the same
person who will never stop fighting him but
on the number for Diggle's brother is still
alive so they infiltrate Damien Darhk's facility
Wolfman Biologics which is actually a reference
to Marv Wolfman who's a long time DC rider
even wrote crisis on infinite earths you can't
throw a rock in the DC universe without hitting
something that Marv Wolfman is touched at
some point but they unmask Andy and it's not
a trick it's not a clone is the actual Andy
Damien Darhk is just co-opted him so Diggle
and Oliver get into it again over what the
right course of action is Diggle is. Is that
all of her wants to pull is season three planned
just like he did with racial goal Oliver's
initial idea is to cozy up with Damien Darhk
taken down from the inside the goals like
do you do that last year it went terribly
do not do it again all of her on the other
side of the coin is telling Diggle not to
give up on his brother he deserves the benefit
of the doubt and by the end they both come
around Oliver takes Damien Darhk on in the
light of day and Diggle tries to help his
brother the interesting thing about that is
there are consequences Diggle's brothers like
yeah I did all that terrible stuff I'm a terrible
person in Damien Darhk is obviously going
to retaliate against Oliver so doing the right
thing won't necessarily lead to a good outcome
but on my number two WTF see you also thinks
that she has a better way of better waving
killing is going to try and embrace this darkness
inside her to take down Damien Darhk something
about the state of her soul backfired against
Damien Darhk when he tried to lay hands on
her so she's like okay I'm in a try and use
this but is intrigued is Merlyn looks here
this is obviously not going to end well you
raise your hand if you thought that she was
actually going to go to that pedophile the
minute that Merlyn offered that solution is
like wow they are really laying it on thick
want to seem like she is wrong choice to make
like this is the worst human beings could
possibly imagine he doesn't deserve to live
and he really doesn't deserve to live with
the is a good person she's not going to actively
campaign for murdering people if you didn't
catch it either Damien Darhk also joked and
called her princess Meredith is just a brave
reference because of the red and the arrows
and finally on my number one WTF Mayor Oliver
Queen versus Damien Darhk I'm just gonna go
ahead and call Amir now I do feel like we
all think dollars gonna win his campaign that
is Damien's looking at him there at the end
of the episode use get the sense that he is
going to retaliate hard in the next episode
like the next episode of arrow is the second
part of the big legends of tomorrow crossover
that is like the collected two-hour episodes
can introduce Vandal Savage I do feel like
he's going to be a part of hive that I do
think there are other people that are in hive
that will show up is kind like Hydra it's
a very complex organization Damien Darhk Vandal
Savage are the only people you're going to
see with any authority but what can happen
is is the story will start on the flash will
learn more about Hawkman in Hawkgirl that
will crossover with Vandal Savage to arrow
that episode is again the air for two weeks
is right next week is going to be a break
I mean I'll also do bonus videos and and stuff
like that but there's no new episode next
week of the flash or arrow no need to freak
out because the cast is going to heroes and
villains fan Fest so there's any videos to
be made for stuff that comes out of that all
totally do that to they said they're going
to be doing some fun stuff I don't know what
that is they may have announced like to have
some special surprise but all in all I felt
like it was a good episode I don't think it
Tita things quite as much is last week's episode
of the flash like it seem like they were ceding
more big things there's been a little bit
more mysterious with the reveals that it's
made we got to see the atom again he really
just reminded us that hey I'll be around to
help but I'm not coming back full time that's
what all that Palmer tech talk was with Felicity
he did have a pretty bad ass save during that
last big fight I actually thought it was the
flash for a minute when he zoomed in superquick
is a weight what was that but I think the
best character moment was when Diggle showed
up almost like a in about time he showed up
and he was like my brother needed me the green
one such a great arrow moment and it just
shows you that all of her is every bit Diggle's
brother is Andy is like you have your blood
relatives then you have the family that you
choose in the whole question of what would
you do to protect your families is a big theme
across the flash and arrow this season like
you have are is trying to fix her family and
most of the Laurel trying to fix her family
all over trying to fix his family and fix
his family of the city like the city is literally
his family for my next video will be for that
flareup trailer I was waiting to see if they
post new footage the promo that they aired
after arrow which is the exact same footers
they did after the flash so I'll do a video
for that explain what's going on with Hawkman
in Hawkgirl because they're tying their back
story to Vandal Savage with Vandal Savage
comes after Hawkgirl like that's the reason
he comes into the story so I'll explain what's
going on with that it's a little bit different
from the comics but they're taking a lot of
classic Hawkman Hawkgirl stories and tying
it in with just a society stuff is going to
be awesome and don't forget Jessica Jones
drops on Friday I'll be doing a whole bunch
of videos for that for those that are asking
about Supergirl this week I am planning on
doing a new video I just don't know which
day it's going to come on so you can just
follow me on twitter and Facebook for updates
on when videos are posting especially with
Jessica Jones stuff happening so while you
guys wait for all that stuff to drop you can
click here for last night's episode of the
flash and you can click here to catch up on
last night's Agents of SHIELD, they did some
really cool Captain America Red Skull stuff.
So you guys gotta check it out. thank you
so much for watching, everybody high five
and I'll see you tonight!